the inaugural tag global spirits awards
begin wednesday at the delano this
global competition will last over four
days and feature 100 categories here to
tell us more is renowned mixologist the
creator of the awards this is tony abu
ghanam good to see you friend hey jc how
are you it's always great having you on
the show it's a pleasure to be back and
especially to talk about the tag global
spirits order okay what can we expect at
this award show well it's four days of
judging spirits but like mentioned 100
categories we've got judges coming from
four different continents to judge but
what we've done jc that's really fun is
we've incorporated consumer events for
enthusiasts okay so people watching
right now what can they do we come down
and partake will be judges what can we
do you can't judge yet all right maybe
by the time we're done you can
we kick it off on thursday the 24th
that's a welcome reception at libertine
social we'll have chef sean mclean's
food there we're going to have walking
around with all the great stations then
on friday we have force festive dinners
we have patron dinner at border grill we
have campari dinner at lupo tito's is
going to be at libertine social and then
the russells are here from wild turkey
along with garrison whiskey out of texas
at strip steak all right you have a lot
in front of us here today we have what
are we gonna do what are you showing me
today well first of all i want to teach
you how to taste okay okay we have two
glasses here with the same whiskey
we designed this glass for the
competition so what i want you to do is
i just want you to nose it out of this
glass first look
smells good yeah yeah but it's kind of
mild right it doesn't really
i smell it though you smell it no yeah
that's you get your nose in there i like
that you got to get in there you tell me
well all right now with the tag
universal spirits glass get that
get in there and just
stronger i really smell it it really
gets the life all the nuances wow
bourbon
you get the caramel the vanilla the
cinnamon spice and this is what the
judges will be using is this special
glass of yours yeah along with my
partners uh david grafshi and julia
bermejo we sat down and designed this
glass because i like your style gotta
taste it
so now that we've selected the whiskey
we're going to make a cocktail okay i'm
going to put you to work right sounds
good put about four ounces of for
russell's reserve ten one two three four
yeah that good measurement what's this
uh that's a
demurrara syrup so it's a raw sugar
syrup so how much two bar spoons so not
much about a half an ounce
perfect okay all right and then about
four dashes of angostura bitters as
we're making this i know there's a big
uh the gal at the end is a charity taco
thank you talk about that as i'm making
my drink the gala is benefiting the
helen david relief fund which is a
charity that i founded 12 years ago to
benefit bartenders and families going
through cancer so it's in memory of my
cousin helen david who ran a bar for 70
years and uh very very thrilled that
that's going to be the final event up at
skyfall rivera you can get tickets still
to all of these events at the uh with
the website at the end of the year all
right let's take a look in there
we'll put some icing your cousin was a
bartender for 70 years she ran the
brassiere bar in port yard michigan for
70 years bartending is in your blood
that's what makes you so good tony it's
in my blood all right give that a stir
nice and cold
um
it's a that's a beautiful fashion not
chicken noodle soup come on
sexy swank come on
what are you judging my stirring skills
oh all right now the hawthorne strainer
fits right in there all right and then
you just go ahead and pour that out into
these two
old-fashioned ways i'm a big fan of ice
cubes and i love your ice cubes oh thank
you directional freezing is the key
jason sport right there yeah and then
save it a little for me oh sorry tony
well you could have poured mine too but
i'll go ahead i guess it's the proper
thing is to pour your drink first
a little
swath of orange orange in there
a couple this is gonna be great because
i mean you can troll these different
cocktails and drinks this week as you
guys judge the best of the best cheers
my friend dad good thank you tony always
great to see this taste is real fast
oh i got hair i didn't even see it hair
is growing on my chest
hair is just growing on my chest my
friend wow thank you tony tag global
spirits awards are happening february
23rd through the 26th for more
information go to tag
spiritsawards.com now in today's
entertainment headlines the oscars have
rolled out their covet protocol